number one problem in families our lives
are chaotic Ellen Galinsky of the
families and Work Institute asked a
thousand children if you could be
granted one wish about your parents what
would it be the parents predicted the
kids would say spend more time with them
but they were wrong the kids said they
wanted their parents to be less tired
and less stress so how do we become less
stressed the number one thing that I
found in looking at high functioning
families is that they adapt all the time
I thought as a parent I'll make a few
rules I'll stick to them it'll be easy
turns out it doesn't work that way you
need a system to adapt but you can't
adapt all the time if you're fighting
over the broccoli on Tuesday are trying
to get the mittens on to go to school on
Thursday morning you don't want to have
the conflict in that actual moment and
so we have adapted a system that many
families are doing and it's called a
family meeting and we meet 15-20 minutes
every Sunday night and we ask three
questions taken from agile development
which is a system that began in the
software world that has now taken over
management and the three questions are
what worked well in our family this week
what didn't work well and what would we
agree to work on in the week ahead and
here's the key to the whole thing we
actually allow our kids with adult
supervision help pick their own rewards
and punishments it sounds crazy anybody
who has not done it thinks the kids will
be incredibly relaxed anybody who's done
it knows the kids are very very strict
in fact our girls are like little
Stalin's we constantly have to dial them
back so let's take this week we're
working on overreacting a common problem
that parents have we say to our kids
okay give me a reward and one says if we
get five minutes of overreacting this
week if we get under that we get a
sleepover if we're over that we have to
do one pushup for every minute over five
minutes first of all I would never pick
that reward and Punishment secondly it's
actually that thinking that I'm really
after here and then my other daughter
says is that one five minute
overreaction or ten 30-second
overreactions
I love that I could never have
created that sense of involvement the
latest research is showing the kids who
plan their own schedules set their own
work actually evaluate their own
progress or actually building up their
brains their cortexes are getting bigger
and they are taking more control over
their lives and this is really the point
nothing is top-down in the world anymore
not business not sports not government
not religion you can't just get your
kids to 16 and say go off and make
decisions and and enter your lives you
need to give them the practice that they
need in order to become independent so
here's a way with parental involvement
mind you we're still setting the rules
here that lets your kids practice so the
key point is here to reduce stress
actually offload some of the
responsibility to children empower them
wherever possible and you'll help
prepare them to be the adults you want
them to be so a couple questions about
the family meeting things that might go
wrong question number one how old do
kids need to be okay maybe a two or
three year old is not old enough but we
have found by four or five kids are
actually ready to engage this
conversation and one tip to get them to
the table is we put the allowance at the
end to make sure that they want to stick
around on the other end of the scale how
old can kids be and still have these
meetings how do you get a 12 or 13 or a
15 year old to come to the table for one
of these meetings sooner or later your
teenager is going to come to you and say
can I go to Johnny's house on Friday
night I know I'm not supposed to work
can I extend my curfew and what you say
is we're not gonna have this
conversation now when I'm flossing my
teeth or where I'm trying to get
breakfast on the table we're gonna have
a time a safe zone every week so the
point is the message to kids is there's
this safe zone where you're going to get
to ask the questions and the message to
parents is when you want to be having
that fight or when it's so chaotic there
is no time you simply have got to get to
the doctor's or you simply have to get
dinner on the table so that you can run
off to your meeting after work you say I
don't need to have every crisis in every
moment there is a safe time at the end
of the week where everyone's going to
get to air their ideas you're going to
be sitting at the same level you're
going to
your voices are gonna be low and you're
gonna know this is the one time of week
that we're going to be mindful about it
what it means to be part of our family